we're here with an astounding individual
is Professor Robert Horvitz he is from
MIT but notably a Nobel Prize winner
back in 2012 for your work in oncology
in cancer welcome and talk to us so you
say it's like coming home because you
work with individuals in Cambridge on
your work in oncology but it's a huge
personal price that people pay when it
comes to cancer but there's phenomenal
economic prices as well as in there in
terms of just the sheer scale of money
you feel that's being paid on cancer at
the moment the personal or obvious both
to patients and to caregivers the
economic may not be so obvious for
example a number i saw it's not totally
current was 835 billion dollars for the
year 2008 in the US alone that is an
enormous cost in terms of workforce and
and death disability these costs are
frankly unmatched by the rather meniscal
investments that have been going in to
the research that really will lead to
the breakthroughs to cause treatments
and cures for this horrible disease tell
us about the excitement that might be
being seen at the moment of the
potential breakthroughs you've been
working with them where are we starting
to see these trends make a difference
and actually the fight against is
pandemic beginning to win well the
traditional cancer cures are basically
things like chemotherapy and radiation
therapy and what they do is kill cells
the problem is they kill not only cancer
cells but also healthy cells and
sometimes even patients and so what's
been needed is something with much more
specificity and and today there are a
number of breakthroughs that have really
led to those kinds of specificities the
first is the Human Genome Project which
was very much driven up from this
country and in the United States and the
collaboration and from the Human Genome
Project we now know
all of the genes in the human genome
which means it's been possible to
identify all of the genes in the cancer
of a particular cancer patient knowing
the specific genes that are abnormal and
a cancer means that those genes can be
targeted the second thing that's new and
they really taken the world of oncology
cancer biology by surge is that cancer I
mean people probably know cancer isn't
infectious if I put cancer cells into an
animal that animal wouldn't get cancer
and the reason is the animal has an
immune system it protects against cancer
occasionally a patient with cancer will
recover and what's happening in that
case is that the patient's immune system
somehow has been able to recognize and
attack that cancer today biologists have
figured out what it is that keeps the
immune system from in general attacking
cancer cells and has learned to unleash
that innate ability and attack a cancer
in a patient why should we be looking in
terms of the industry at the moment then
in terms of future trends are is the
investment starting to reap rewards
should we be looking at certain
geographies where these steps are being
made where these breakthroughs are
getting close the investment is
unquestionably reaping rewards I don't
know that the breakthroughs are
necessarily geographic specific anymore
that industry and science are geographic
specific and of course there are some
specific aspects to that but the
breakthroughs are coming from a
combination of the science and the
technology at an ever-increasing rate
and basically there there are multiple
ways that we now think about and are
able to affect cancer we can block their
growth of cancer cells we can cause
cancer cells to die in fact that biology
was what sent me to Stockholm some years
ago we also can prevent the progression
the spread
neways in all three of these areas
coupled with the technologies in the new
science are really what's needed to
breakthroughs we remain positive thank
you very much been wonderful speaking of
course professor Robert Horvitz not
often that you get to speak to a Nobel
Prize winner certainly in such important
areas such as cancer it looks as though
that breakthrough is getting ever closer
handing things back to you in the studio
gentlemen